it was by a learned scholar of that time
Zade IB sah and I said look this man he
had put the dots together and he was
expecting a messenger like they were to
come and he had came and he was looking
at his life and everything fit except
one thing that he had read in the Torah
talking
about what is
forbearance that somebody harm
you and he is deserving your
punishment and you're able to punish
you're aware of their harm and you do
not need them and you refrain from
punishing them and rather you treat them
kindly the
forbearance that this messenger would
have so he wanted to test the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam I
was able to verify accept this one that
when you increase dealing with him in an
ignorant way
his forbearance increases so I'm telling
my kids this that we're extracting
guidance we have a blueprint for how we
need to live our lives that's a
blessing and he had found that the
Muslims were in desperation so I decided
to test him in this area so he went to
the mosque one day when an incident
happened in front of him that some
Muslims needed desperately some
financial help
and they needed some money so he put up
he said look I'm going to give you a
loan for one year I will lend you the
money for one year of course no user
okay he came back after 3 months grabb
the messenger of Allah by his
neck started to insult him can you
imagine someone put their hands on you
go back home but I was born here
you what do we do what are you about to
to do standing in front of the mid with
guns what are you going to snap
unfortunately you have some Muslims
getting out of line getting ghetto that
doesn't help the daah look at the
forbearance of the messenger sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
amazing the guy's got his hands on him
Omar he's got he's like let me get
him so he insults him you guys you don't
pay your debts he's doing he setting it
up look he promised a year came back
after 3 months he wants to test him so
the prophet s says go pay him and give
him some more cuz you frighten him you
should you should advised him in a nice
way om so
for scaring him give him more make a
long story short he ends up paying it
back the man says do you know who I am
ask you he said no why why' you snap
like you're
acting in this way to the messenger of
Allah I was testing T in him there was
just one thing I had connected the dots
and I saw that indeed this was the
messenger but there was one thing
holding me back it was this thing that I
needed to test his forbearance and
forbearance means when you're in a
position that someone's oppressing you
someone's bringing harm upon you and
you're able to punish them back like the
prophet s he could have just said go get
him right now it's finished
done but he didn't this was a learned
man of that time a Jewish scholar this
isn't wasn't a Layman and he accepted
Islam take that to the
streets we have to be
forbearing to a whole another level
because there's a lot of heat coming on
people they don't understand the beauty
of Islam The Message of Islam and they'
Fallen victim to the islamophobia
machine so forbearance remember this
patience just as brother Eddie was
saying a moment ago that we live in a
time where you know people they don't
understand our religion they don't know
what Islam is you have people sitting on
foxs commentating and telling us who
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
when they've never read a Muslim
biography of his you know they've only
read critique of him they've only read
the story of him that actually was
written by people who never liked him in
the first place why don't you read a
critique of his from a Muslim why don't
you read his life from a muslim's
perspective you want to know who the
prophet Muhammad was come and talk to me
let me tell you who he was actually
scrap the talk let me show you who he
was you know he was a person that smiled
he was a lovable person his family loved
him to bits his children loved him to
bits for those of you who think that the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
an abusive man I swear my God you can
never provide me with a single case a
single scenario in his entire life where
he ever raised his hand on any of his
family members even once is that true or
false is that an exaggeration not an
exaggeration this is an academic Claim
by the way I instruct at a seminary I'm
an instructor at a seminary I teach on
an academic level this is actually a
factual claim this is not true it's not
possible all these claims that the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
out there to murder everyone that wasn't
a Muslim absolutely false think about
this he lived in a city called Medina
before he arrives there all non-muslim
when he comes there a fraction of
society accepts Islam and the other
fraction remains as non-muslim until he
passes away and even after that so I ask
you a question if Muslims were supposed
to annihilate everyone on the face of
this Earth who weren't Muslims there was
only one of two possibilities that would
remain in his city either everyone would
be Muslim and forced into Islam or they
would be non-muslim and all the Muslims
would have been killed simple yes no
simple logic
right but 10 years later what happens we
know there are many benefits to the use
of black seed according to the authentic
statements of the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon them that's why I
used the black seed by Tes and 50% of
the profits from your order will go
towards establishing the dean Center the
Masjid and mega dawa Center use promo
code the dean show for 15% off I'm sure
all of you know Eddie from the dean show
and I'm sure that you've all heard about
the dean center now you don't want to
miss on this opportunity the brother has
been around for a long time when I
became Muslim that was a show that I
used to watch it was one of the shows
that I actually was interviewed on and
since then I've kept in touch with Eddie
and we've cooperated and participated in
many things together alhamdulillah by
the blessings of Allah now you guys have
to do your part this is for the umah
there's so many people in this world who
need The Message of Islam but the
question is now what you're going to do
what are you going to do with your money
with what you have what are you going to
do to help the umah to help someone
who's been around for 20 years doing
dawa you've enjoyed the shows you've
enjoyed the interviews you've enjoyed
now it's your turn support the dean
Center